no no I do not look like Jason Biggs
[ __ ] I kind of do American Reunion I so
it's been a few years since the American
Pie movies like American Wedding wrapped
up it was a trilogy it was done they
were like oh wait couple years ago we
could have had some sort of reunion
movie let's do that now so now we have
American Reunion so American Reunion is
the reunion story of the American Pie
crew pretty easy to get them all back
together also because most of them
haven't acted in about ten years and it
really does show oz was in Street
Fighter The Legend of chun-li and he was
terrible in that too in any case the
American Pie crew they're all grown up
they're about 30 years old they're
married or they're married they have
kids or they're just successful in life
or not so successful and don't have kids
or they're not married that's a nice
little plethora it's pretty much what
happens to people after high school I
think everything you need to know and
the tone of American Reunion can be
found in the opening scene in this movie
Michelle the Bandcamp girl she's
bouncing her kid on the bed you know
trying to get him to go to sleep Jason
Biggs just on the computer you can tell
the romance spark is gone she goes into
the shower Jason Biggs tries to tug it
real quick and short shenanigans ensue
so yeah either American reunions kind of
a comedy kind of a drama in which it
shows that the romance spark is gone in
a marriage or it does 90s lowbrow
highschool humor in the year 2012
in any case nothing really fits together
well almost like the writers were like
[ __ ] I don't know how to make people
laugh and make this relevant because
they're all 30 years old now and they're
not funny
I don't know throw them into some high
school scenarios that was funny back in
the day maybe it'll be funny now and
that kind of feeds into what I think is
the problem of a movie like this if you
go all dramatic it loses that fun spark
that American Pie had but if you try to
make it what American Pie was and you're
like why are these 30 year olds acting
like high school students it doesn't
make sense in which case that is the
dilemma it just felt like it was written
by a couple different people the movie
was written by a couple different people
it was almost like one did the humor one
did the drama now you have a movie that
doesn't always mesh so much like this
movie doesn't know what his target
audience actually is is it high school
students now or high school students who
are high school students in 1999 the
whole movies not like this I would say
the last half or maybe last third of the
movie that actually had some laughs in
it for me a couple laughs before that
but after that it was like okay this
movie really focused in it was like all
right here's the point here's your
and it was funny but I will tell you
this most of the big laughs or maybe all
the big laughs we're due to Eugene Levy
Jim's dad you're gonna hear this in
every review about this movie this dude
steals the movie they should have called
it American Pie presents Jim's dad the
guy was funny as hell he was almost like
he was like yeah you kids want to know
what it is to make people laugh all
right the moment Shannon Elizabeth
removes her lips from my junk I will
show you how to make people laugh dude
killed it in this movie every scene
every he was the man I just went like
this he was so the man some laughs
Eugene Levy steals the show but I'm just
saying if you pay more than matinee for
this movie don't do that American
Reunion is a good time if you're drunk
and now is a party the whole movie kind
of looked like what Stifler really was a
30 year old man trying to relive the
glory days of high school so your
favorite American Pie movie what is it
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]